the jurogan experience so
uh what do you remember from that moment
on
uh when i when i regained consciousness
it wasn't real quick it wasn't real
walking right up um it was real slow
it was dim uh
my consciousness was kind of like in and
out for a while
i didn't know where i was the pain and
the feeling that
that i was mortally wounded something um
something was so wrong inside i i felt
like i was dying
and this is what really fueled the panic
when i finally laid eyes on these
creatures
uh of course you know all of the
mental programming that we get from
hollywood that
aliens are invading monsters you know
didn't help but i instantly associated
this feeling of
of dying with pain with them
so i was combative immediately
where were you i was lying on my back
on a raised table there was a light
above me
it was not real bright it was um
not so bright that i couldn't um
you know see the outline of the of the
fixture but uh
would the fixture look like kind of like
that only much larger
just a soft uh glow
and uh in the movie there's a
little bit of striking on the part of
the aliens
against me uh that didn't happen
i lashed out at them the one
closest to me i i felt really weak i
didn't have enough strength to
to do much so when i my arm
contacted him he just fell back very
unexpectedly easy into the other one
and i rolled off the table in the other
direction
and uh they came around the table and
the three of them were coming towards me
and i just grabbed something from behind
me
an object off of the uh shelf there
and started swinging it at them what was
the object
it was just some large uh long
cylinder or rod uh
glass some clear material i wasn't
studying it i was looking at them and
swinging wildly screaming threats
they stopped
and i was planning on
attacking more fully just making way
past them the only doorway i could see
was on the other side of them
and it looked like a doorway yeah it
looked like a doorway just uh
you know what did they look like
um i guess it's a pretty typical
description nowadays
very large eyes hairless
two eyes nose mouth
i didn't see them speak
or no change in the expressions
and uh to me that
and in the face of all the screaming and
the
fear that i was uh
projecting uh their lack of reaction
probably just
added to my panic but uh did they feel
like they were
a living creature or did they feel like
they were a robot
like well they were without expression
i'll say that but
you know i've had 45 years to think
about that in more recent years i think
well maybe
if they're telepathic and it's
developed enough to where they don't
need to talk
they also don't need facial expression
right
and so their ability to communicate with
each other would be much
richer and more complete than we have
and
speech and frowns or smiles or whatever
would become
obsolete pretty quick yeah well that is
a
theory about where human beings are
headed
if we continue to evolve that we will
one day reach this
point where the biological limitations
of our
monkey bodies will slowly start to fade
away we'll have
different abilities different abilities
well why would we need to
uh frown or smile if if you can save
much more and also their their
musculature did their
musculature did they look like smooth
like they had no
no clear muscles yeah they were pretty
smooth very light
when i when i hit the one it fell back
into the other one pretty easily
like he weighed hardly anything like a
little kid yeah
that was most terrifying experience of
my life but
when i when i tell the story and try to
relate to people i'm trying to
communicate
what i experienced and how utterly
utterly traumatic that was and how it
was so devastating i was
you know on the verge of catatonic for
weeks after it happened but
uh i don't i don't want to
relate this story in order to uh
inspire fear because i've had enough
time to think about it
that i think that it was unwarranted
that my reaction was
uh just due to my ignorance of the
situation
the fact that i was returned at all is
pretty significant you know
yeah uh the idea that
these beings are just uh kidnapping
people willy-nilly and
doing terrible things to them i i don't
subscribe to that theory
now i try to separate what i actually
experienced from things that i've
concluded
just from thinking about it but it seems
to me
that uh i mean they've been seen
uh observed there have been sightings
for all you know before i was born had
you heard of the betty and barney hill
story before you were abducted
no i probably had but
if i i thought if they had some sort of
sinister intentions it'd be a done deal
they wouldn't be
sneaking around hiding and uh
yeah i believe with that level of
technology
look at it this way human beings just
virtually
everything technological that we have is
just a few hundred years old
before that the most technological thing
we had was fire
and in just uh the last
um 50 years the
progress of our science has grown
to far overshadow everything we had
accomplished in thousands of years
before that
so i'm thinking um
what astronomers tell us about these
other star systems
is that they could be hundreds of
thousands millions or maybe
billions of years older than us so if we
accomplished
the kind of technology that we have in a
few decades
what is possible with millions of years
of development i mean
we couldn't begin to recognize what
they're capable of right
so i think it's presumptuous for people
to say oh they could never do that
it really is an interesting conundrum
because
we know what we can do and we know where
we came from we have a very clear
history of technology
when it comes to humans and we also know
that there are planets
surrounding stars all throughout our
galaxy and all throughout the universe
but we're still skeptical it's so funny
and so first
it is but for a guy like you who's
actually encountered it
even though you saw it it had to
not seem real oh yeah you're questioning
your sanity for sure i mean it was like
i was practically catatonic for days
afterwards
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now to
get this full episode
of the joe rogan experience